حسنًا ، لديهم رؤية عظيمة تتمثل في
أن يصبحوا أقل اعتمادًا بشكل أساسي على
القطاع بأكمله في الدولة التي بها عدد كبير من
السكان ، وبالتالي فإن سوقًا محليًا كبيرًا
لديك المهارات إذا قمت
بتثقيف موظفيك إذا كنت تقوم ببناء
بنى تحتية للتنويع بعيدًا
عن الطاقة والنفط إلى  التصنيع
في الخدمات ولديك الآن
الموارد المالية ولديك
فرصة سانحة حوالي 10 15 عامًا ، كان هناك
تحديث اجتماعي
جيد جدًا معظم الشباب السعوديين
سعداء لأن التحديث الاجتماعي
الآن بحاجة أيضًا إلى
التحديث الاقتصادي يجب أن يكون تصور 2030
يتم تنفيذها عاجلاً وليس آجلاً إذا
قاموا بذلك بالطريقة الصحيحة بحيث يمكن أن يظلوا
بالتأكيد قصة نجاح للشرق
الأوسط أكثر تنوعًا أقل
اعتمادًا على الطاقة وبالتالي أكثر
استقرارًا من الناحية الاقتصادية والاجتماعية
وغير ذلك